what i want to do is start with an
expression like 4x plus 18 and see if we
can rewrite this as the product of two
expressions essentially we're going to
try to factor this
and the key here is to
figure out
are there any common factors to both 4x
and 18 and we can cut we can factor that
common factor out we're essentially
going to be reversing the distributive
property so for example what is the
largest number that is the or i could
really say the largest expression that
is divisible into both 4x and 18.
well 4x is divisible by 2 because we
know that 4 is divisible by 2 and 18 is
also divisible by 2. so we can rewrite
we can rewrite 4x as being as being 2
times 2x
2 times 2x
if you multiply that it's obviously
going to be 4x and then we can write 18
as the same thing as 2 times
2 times 9. and now it might be clear
that you know one when you apply the
distributive property you usually end up
with a step that looks something like
this now we're just going to
undistribute the 2 right over here we're
going to factor the 2 out let me
actually just draw that so we're going
to factor we're going to factor the 2
out and so this is going to be
times
2x
2 x plus 9
plus
9.
and if you were to wanted to multiply
this out it would be 2 times 2x plus 2
times 9. it would be exactly this which
you would simplify as this right up here
so there we have it we have written this
as the product of two exp two
expressions two times two x plus nine
let's do this again
so let's say
that i have
let's say that i have twelve
plus
twelve plus
let me think of something interesting
12 plus 32x
32 actually since we just to get a
little bit of
variety here let's put a y here
12 plus 32y
well what's the largest number that's
divisible into both 12 and 32 2 is
clearly divisible into both but so is 4
and let's see it doesn't look like
anything larger than 4 is divisible into
both 12 and 32 the greatest common
factor of 12 and 32 is 4 and y is only
divisible into the second term not into
this first term right over here so it
looks like 4 is the greatest common
factor so we could rewrite each of these
as a product of 4 and something else so
for example 12 we can rewrite as
we can rewrite as 4
times 3
and 32 we can rewrite so this is going
to be plus
times 4 times well if you divide 32y by
4 it's going to be
8 y and now once again we can factor out
the 4. so this is going to be 4
times
plus 8y
3 plus 8y and once you do more and more
examples of this you're going to find
that you can just kind of do this step
all at once you can say hey what's the
largest what's the largest number that's
divisible into both of these what's 4 so
let me factor a 4 out 12 divided by 4 is
3. 32y divided by 4 is 8y